chinatown baby
when i think about chinatown the first
thing that comes to mind is all the food
i cannot imagine in new york without
chinatown chinatown businesses
pretty much invented the word hero it is
the embodiment of the american dream i
think that's worth fighting for don't
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since 9 11 really this part of town just
has been faced with one major change to
the next colvin hit chinatown real bad
of course the rhetoric of kung flo
didn't help at all
during covet half of chinatown wasn't
qualified to apply for aid
although media attention on all these
anti-asian hate crimes has died down
considerably that doesn't mean that
they're not happening i think the more
these attacks happen the less people
come to these neighborhoods we also have
plans of a larger jail that's coming
so many businesses have been forced to
shut down because their physical
location is where the jail is going to
be built
there is so much of what makes chinatown
unique i go for things that i can't get
at american supermarkets so i'll like
very specific herbs or vegetables if i
want the ingredients for hotpot i need
to go to chinatown to get those
ingredients without a lot of these
things chinatown just becomes
another neighborhood in new york so i
hope that we're able to preserve the
culture that has always made chinatown
what it is
[Music]
could i just get a veggie roll please 5
50. here you go
awesome thank you so much have a good
one
i love having all my sauces it's a rice
roll musk this my friends is the
breakfast for champs right here we have
carrots woody or mushrooms some
scallions it's very stretchy i used to
be embarrassed to eat this for breakfast
i was jealous i was like why can't i
have froot loops
but now that i'm an adult why would i
eat froot loops i got this
[Music]
zen chinatown love is an organization
that forms at the start of the pandemic
and the goal of our organization is
really to provide relief for businesses
in new york city's nine china towns
a lot of businesses like tony's didn't
really have too many options for
financial relief especially in these
ethnic enclaves where cash is such a big
currency here they don't really have
banking relationships to apply for the
ppp loan and all these other things that
major
american businesses had the privilege of
i knew that i had to do something i was
raised in this neighborhood and it felt
strong to watch them crumble you know
with tony's we started off with
some of our fast financial relief
programs which involves building a small
website for them to really reach more
audiences and it just gives them another
way to tell their an amazing story that
i think really needs to be broadcast
[Music]
i always describe ling as my first
sunshine hello friend she really
inspires me because her family has a
restaurant in floral park and it just
felt so good as well when ling's parents
agreed to work with us as merchants
themselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is the kitchen this is where my
dad usually is
immediately after school i would come to
the restaurant because i need to make
sure that i was at the business during
rush hour this is the chicken fried rice
that my mom is making
you have to be really fast because if
not then when it gets really busy
there's just a really large backlog of
orders
but you can't go wrong with the chicken
with broccoli here it's just a classic
and it always hits with the white rice
so this is the kung po chicken which is
a spicy diced chicken topped with
peanuts
the shrimp with garlic sauce so you have
um the shrimp with a bunch of mixed
vegetables like onions celery carrots
and pepper
juice
[Music]
i was part of the chinatown love the
founding team and we're all
brainstorming on what we could do to
help these small businesses and bring
these very small mom-and-pop businesses
who are traditionally like very off the
grid no social media presence no website
to the spotlight i was very fortunate
that i still had a job but i was seeing
my parents not have a job anymore and
this was their entire life and so
we set up a fundraising page for them on
the chinatown website they told their
story why they came here what their
motivation is for running a restaurant
so we would on board these merchants
interview them understand what their
story was and really tell their story to
the world and let people know that they
are such an integral part of our
communities and they shouldn't just be
erased and then we would basically try
to fundraise as much as possible for
this merchant in this case for my dad
and a hundred percent of the donations
go back towards the merchant
another merchant is jefferson lee from
47 division we actually came across him
because he wrote a very funny reddit
post that read it post went viral
you want some of them dim sum rips them
itty bitty little tiny cuts of ribs
small just like your feelings when your
ex left you got him at 359 a pound
my threaded post was actually cooked up
while i was on uh on a delivery on the
box truck uh the truck right out there
and i was just like yo like
what can we do
to help out how can i reach larger
demographic
i did not expect to touch that many
people
new york city is expensive every
immigrant community is going to go
through the same struggle
so i saw that as a way out for them to
keep feeding their families
everybody wants to save money bro
[Music]
you got foot fetish uh i got some
chicken feet right here bro
this is what it's all about
you grow up the way you grow up and you
don't really think it's out of the norm
until later on when you ask other people
how they grew up and they're like oh
[ __ ] like you go to disney world oh you
go go on trips i went to a farm like
that was my trip to pick up [ __ ] i would
actually call this my primary home
i spent so much time here
and this is oxtail i know all the
jamaicans watching this are getting
pretty excited for that
i never really envisioned myself
doing this
when you you're a kid of an immigrant
family you're [ __ ] translating [ __ ]
for them or you learn how to hustle at a
young age my dad used to work here well
after 18 hour days to drive a cab
afterwards as i got older my parents got
older too they needed more help
nobody wants the parents to work
themselves down to the bone
[Music]
the american dream to come up from
nothing and to become something
you know like asians in america we make
a 5.6 of the population something like
two-thirds of us live at or below the
poverty line
to other people's standards this might
fall short
but to us
this is representative of my family's
struggle coming to
to america
i think that's worth fighting for don't
you
[Music]
helen from saigon social
i admire her so much helen's always been
about using her skills and her ability
as a new chef to give back to the
community which is so important for the
future of chinatown this cyclical
acknowledgement of knowing that i exist
because people existed before me
today we actually have a group of
seniors these are typical patrons that
come every week to pick up meals from
our board and meal program
hello
these are members of the community that
are in need of food service we connect
them to a nutritious meal and holland
has been part of this
project since the inception
there so today we have three options we
have a
salmon
raised with tomatoes
and then we also have lemongrass career
ribs over rice and then a chicken noodle
soup chicken though
now
through these conversations like hey
where do you live and then they tell me
like across the street and so then it's
just one person then it's like 10 then
it becomes dozens when it comes down to
it food truly connects people
more than a meal is a program that took
a community approach to bringing europe
back to life and when people say you
know we're feeding people and we're
solving food insecurity and hunger
that's
doesn't work without the buy-in of the
whole entire community so what we're
trying to do here is create a connection
introduce conversations and break bread
because when there's good food and good
people around the table magic happens
a lot of people think that oh hey you do
a lot for the community you've provided
a lot of like support and assistance but
truly i feel like the community is is
the reason why i've been able to
persevere so long throughout the whole
entire pandemic
it's so important to have that
connection and that relationship with
with your elders coming to a new country
starting all over not knowing the
language
the culture and
yet they're still able to
to stand and to persevere there's a lot
that we can learn from their strengths
and and their values
you
all right
[Music]
he thinks it's very good
[Music]
i just did what i thought i needed to do
because i think if the roles were
reversed my parents would have moved
mountains to make sure i stayed afloat
and so i wanted to do what little i
could to to do the same for them
send chinatown love they were able to
give us a voice our parents generation
everybody else before them they didn't
know the language and they didn't really
go outside the china town so it was more
like shut the [ __ ] up
keep your head down grind out we're the
ones that
are arrogant enough to be like this is
my home tour i'm not a guest i'm not a
guest here in new york city i'm not a
guest here in my country
the other day i was feeling so down from
work and i popped into one of my
favorite restaurants in queens to grab a
bite and the owner was the only one
working there and he provided me that
moment of comfort during a time where
he's probably struggling as well not
everyone has the ability to do that and
that's why i think chinatown business
owners whether they have a supermarket
or pharmacy they're all heroes at the
end of the day because they're always
going to put the needs of their
community before themselves
this is an entire community that has
been built through generations of
immigration and families and love it's
part of what makes new year so great in
my opinion and i think it would be a
real real shame if we lost that
[Music]
wow
beautiful
oh thank you
they dropped off two bags for winston
and myself and
so cute
and then a card dear helen thank you for
your kindness and generosity wishing you
all the best
it's in english and in chinese
[Music]
[Music]